[Music]
there's this guy named sam evans do you
know sam evans sam ovens uh is that the
uh very like slick-backed hair guy
yeah what's his thing consulting.com so
he talks all right so this guy named sam
evans he rubbed me the wrong way for a
long time and looking back i think i was
actually wrong and he seemed like an
alright guy so he had this website
called consulting.com which if i had to
put it at its worst it was basically a
course that was like two thousand to ten
thousand dollars that taught you how to
start a business at best
it's like it like it's an accelerator
and the reality is it just like is a way
to like it's like a community and a
course on starting a company
and he scaled it to like 30 million in
revenue
and
it was just him and he hired all these
people and built this office in new york
and he was posted on social that they're
doing 50 or 60 million in revenue and
then he vanished and he had a youtube
video come out today that says and he
and he just says i'm back he's like for
the past two years i hated life we
scaled too quickly and so we were
spending like 50k a day on facebook ads
and we weren't even making that much
profit so i decided to change everything
and over the last two years we've
crushed it he goes for example in
january
uh this course he goes we got rid of
like there was three courses now we only
sell two or one and last month in
january we made eight hundred thousand
dollars in revenue and our expenses
which includes payroll and buy and paid
ads was sixty thousand dollars
and so basically this guy and and then
he launched this new company called
school which is basically like a
facebook groups alternative because when
he was launching courses he was like you
stink so that is a different story
that's actually cool but this course
business this guy has now
basically let's just times it by ten so
eight million in revenue with six
hundred thousand dollars in expenses is
that nutty or what is that crazy yeah
but it depends is that sustainable and
also is that gonna grow so for example
i know i don't think it's gonna grow but
i think it could be sustainable when i
did the like all access passives like i
was making whatever 50k a month off of
the newsletter i paid newsletter making
50k a month what were my expenses it was
like you know
300 a month for convertkit
uh you know like a va for 500 a month
whatever so it looked nutty but like
that's because i had an audience so i
could just sell into that if i wanted to
grow it i would have had to like you
know my expenses would have had to gone
way up right you know like so it depends
where
yeah maybe his ad spend is really low
now is that because his ads are ultra
efficient or is because he had a long a
big list no they said that they don't
they don't spend ads anymore but
previously they had spent millions and
tens of millions of dollars of ads so
the website definitely already has yeah
uh traffic
traffic yeah so yes it's not like i
talked to somebody who worked there um
pretty early on so i was like this guy
legit like he's legit he's good um
they're like he he lived in new zealand
or something like that he's a digital
marketer
uh then he has consulting.com which is
basically like they had a course they
had a consulting accelerator and they're
basically teaching people how to start
their own business their own consulting
business
and uh they said they told me at the
time that there was like 10 million
dollars of free cash flow a year and
they said that um there it was about 30
million or something in revenue they
said like half of that so like 15 16
million was coming from one product
which was a two or three thousand dollar
course about how to start your own
consulting business and then from there
they upsell you into the five thousand
dollar course about how to create a
course
and then
uh once you get to
five hundred thousand dollars in
consulting revenue then you get to join
a mastermind that will help you get to a
million dollars plus and that'll cost
you 25 or 50 grand or something like
that and so that was their you know that
was their model but you know half of it
was coming from that kind of like entry
level
two to three thousand dollar course um
where they like kind of sell you close
you on the phone
to like get you to buy the course which
is yeah i went through the funnel to
like
so i got him to sell me online
or to do the phone call and i was like i
want to figure this out
it's pretty good man and i gave the guy
a hard time because he's just kind of
weird he just comes off serial kill he
kind of patrick bateman he's kind of
like the patrick bateman of our of our
friend jack smith like the american
psycho version of our friend jack smith
and
so he's like just like a little
off but
that's actually
really
incorrect of me to say because i don't i
think he's just an oddball which is
totally because i don't know the guy
yeah i don't know him and i think that
my judgment is just totally wrong i
think he's an all right guy yeah i think
it's wrong because it's all based on his
haircut
no i watched a lot of this guy's videos
and i was like something is off here and
i he was he was aggressively selling he
is it was the type of guy where you
selling like a private jet uh like a
video on a private jet right so that's
not wrong but it's it's it's you know
your cousins with wrong um
and so i think that it was just kind of
odd
[Music]
you